so in just the past two years the
federal reserve has increased the money
supply in the united states by more than
40 percent in two years during the
covent pandemic the fed bought up more
than five trillion dollars worth of
mortgage back and government securities
the treasury department also borrowed
trillions of dollars for stimulus checks
so what was the effect of that well it
was historic levels of inflation can
they admit that if not why not charlie
gaspino has followed this from the
beginning a senior correspondent of
course at fox business a prolific
business journalist for many decades
we're happy to have him on tonight
charlie thanks so much for coming on so
it seems i mean i'm not an economist but
even i
can see the connection between higher
spending and inflation why can't they
just admit that uh the binder
administration won't admit it uh wall
street is grudgingly admitting it after
being behind it you know you hear people
like jamie dimon and larry fink and
everybody's saying wow you know maybe we
kept the
the the the pedal to the metal too long
and now we're paying the price the
unfortunate thing is that it's not wall
street that is paying the price here
it's average americans uh i mean here's
the thing i grew up in the 70s i'm sure
you remember the 70s a little bit yes my
old man worked three jobs and he worked
three jobs because working-class people
couldn't afford you know everything
putting their kids to school buying them
clothes sneakers whatever and the
mortgage when inflation is raging and
it's a it's a it's a heinous tax on the
on the working class and it's always
propagated by by elites on wall street
and
and in government uh so now we're in a
pickle like how do you get out of it and
it's it's it there's no good choices
here because the biden administration
won't help the supply side of the of the
equation which means how do you increase
supply to meet the demand they won't cut
regulations that would be a smart thing
to do you don't have to cut taxes cut
some regulations be a little more
pro-business friendly uh they won't do
that so alls you have is really the
heavy hammer and it's a sledgehammer of
consistent fed rate increases now you
know markets liked a 75 basis point
increase as opposed to a full point
however how many more of these 75 basis
points are we gonna have to deal with
and and for how long if we don't get rid
of inflation this thing could be going
on until next year if inflation doesn't
go away and that will be a slow grind on
the economy i mean we've really got
ourselves in a pickle here
very quick
almost all the business titans that you
know and cover and have for so long
supported joe biden do they regret it do
you think
they they they do now i mean the thing
is that they did not think he would he
was
this incompetent uh you know i guess
that's the easiest way to say they did
not think he would fill his cabinet with
far left people
uh you know they thought it would be
much more listen this is further to the
left than barack obama's cabinet i mean
larry summers had a place in barack
obama
yeah he doesn't have a place with joe
biden you know no that's that's that's a
really perfect example of it charlie yes
we are great to see each night thank you
anytime
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight